good morning guys it is still dark
Nikita is awake she's got her fishing
clothes on because we are going fishing
we are going to Cape Town hot Bay and
then we have some guests so Clifton
Nikita's brother and also Ross all the
way from America we call him our
American Dad you ready for fishing ready
for fishing let's
go we are about 10:3 I think minutes
away from our location and my stomach is
in trouble uh so we had some food
yesterday you can see Nikita here it's a
little bit dark with the GoPro but she
is enjoying this looks like I need a
toilet and I need a toilet
fast Houston we have a
problem all right we are here but I
don't care about anything right now I'm
just looking for a
toilet I'm going to run it's funny
Nikita stop
laughing morning good morning Sean but I
do need a toilet I do need the toilet
before we go is that okay no problem
it's open good morning good morning good
morning good morning this is our friend
Sean he's going to take us fishing
hoooked on Africa and we're excited but
I need a toilet
first we had some uh we had some pra
carry which was not a good idea
C oh oh Hallelujah a few moments
later so much better you know there's
two things I just realized never eat
prawn Curry before you go fishing and
second we need to appreciate toilets and
toilet paper a lot
more you guys ready sign when you sign
if we die there we go cool got so this
is our
boat Daniel nice to meet you nice to
meet you too you wonderful H Jared Jared
nice to meet you oh okay so there's the
toilet in case I need one toilet
cat and these are theing rods this is
going to be an interesting
day Bonito and Yellow Tail okay when you
ready Sean yeah guys we'll see you when
you get back just but I'll join you
tomorrow thank you
Sean so this is dad's Ross first time on
the ocean first time fishing on the
ocean in South Africa you ready I am
ready and Clifton and Nikita they're
ready they're used to this
ready if we if we together and we don't
have
catchfish there's a lot of seals here
hey hello hello
it's the say on the
camera oo there's some nice dolphins
here just want to show
you
woooo wow
o that is
beautiful man that's so
nice there's a couple of birds here so
we just see
just seeing if we can get anything
here so what are we're doing today is we
are at spot fishing so driving around
seeing if we can see birds or any
strange activity and then we will see
what we can
get
doing your eyes going Nikita your
eyes there you
go thank
[Music]
you
all right all right now I'm ready to
catch a
Marmon those are
huge are you ready
Nikita so the lines are in they're
getting ready look at
Nikita more passion more passion more
energy more energy more fishing more
fishing more footwork more footwork more
footwork more
footwork the lines are
in if you guys look there that's
actually lion's head that's Table
Mountain from the other side most of you
who know Table Mountain you know it's
very flat but from this side from the
ocean that's what it looks like and that
there is Cape
Town but today we don't care about that
we care about the fish only
fish behind us like
6:00
well
so we came here all the way to the other
side and you can see Table Mountain now
there it is from this side and then
there's a whale right here visiting
us the GoPro is never good with distance
but maybe you can see
[Music]
it so take a look at this there's so
many fish
here but it looks like there's nothing
chasing them there's a lot of birds here
in the sky as well
many of
them so we've been trolling for a little
bit but no bites not yet if it's God's
will we'll get something it's just a
waiting
[Music]
game and's take a little bit of a
r waiting for the
fishies
sh we finally got a fish got yay got a
fish forito first
one I missed it
all never eat Bron scar
the toilet look at
that than this is what we call a
Bonito nice Nikita
yes well
done oh the other one you're on that's
good that's good and sting is
on woo finally it's on hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah got it got it oh
the seals got it oh my
goodness other
side sure Jared you're fighting a
seal
yeah
nothing
late yeah there nothing
late there's nothing left of the Bonito
it's
gone there goes your feish s
[Music]
in next is yours next is mine it happens
it happens I went for the seal it's
their house not my
house that's true as long as only went
to the
SE keep it tight it's all good all good
first fish for him just look where the
line
is so this is D Ross's first ever fish
on the ocean wow awesome come on oh
bring him in bring him in we starting to
see other here we go your first fish in
the sea
here we go
YY thank you first fish in the sea not
too bad well done thank you I'm going to
SL yeah and now you could also ask me
why it took me so long to find the
fish you say very different from bass
fishing yes very different but it was
fun right it
was things happen a lot quicker here on
the boat does that's awesome lifton you
have to take um the next one get yours
no that seal took
it the seal took yours so it's all
good nice
nice following yes so the seals are a
bit of a problem they're following
us right
[Music]
there
take we're having some snacks here some
energy bars really really good
and um now it's a bit quiet and I think
I need to go back to the Lube there
because looks like if I go in there the
fish start
biting fish on for Clifton he lost his
earlier so he's got a second
go oh the seal is coming is
coming hurry hurry really coming he's
really coming go go go go come Clon come
come come got it he's got it ah sh reel
in the seal reel in the
seal let me show you this
seal right
here oh man he's got this one as well
tell me if you need any help
[Music]
okay starbard
starboard it's got all the
lines
a and it snapped
fishing for
me LIF second
one
yeah those creatures are nasty they're
terrible they're terrible they're
thieves oh
Clon
yeah the seals they're a bit of a
problem here it's near to Robin Island
and there are many seals
here but today that's where the fish are
seal was coming who called the seal I
saw him
huh who is man who called The
Seal Seal to us two
[Music]
yeah got
it oh
[Music]
no quick the seal got it let me show
you he got a fish got
a I want it to be
fast and I thought if if I'm there
first in the water Yellow Tail that's
awesome so they sing some Yellow Tail in
the water that's really a tasty
fish come on Daniel come on come on come
on fish on Fish
on come on baby you to stay away yeah
hold on hold
[Music]
on
a son what
happened the other
lines that's it lost it the second one
the first one to the seal this one was
just a little bit yeah little difficult
so now we're going to go down the list
the next one is Nikita we get a bite de
bengu jackass Penguins yeah look at the
jackass Penguins jackass
[Music]
you never know what you're going to get
when you're in the
ocean so now we've seen whale we've seen
Dolphins we've
seen a lot of seals taking our fish but
it's their their territory their land so
it's fine their sea land and then some
penguins this is
awesome Lefton is checking out the fish
there you know this is quite special
because uh you sit here it's relaxing
it's out away from the noise the bustle
of the city life and then just look at
this
view stable Mountain there Cape
Town Nikita are you enjoying yourself
yeah Ros you enjoying yourself le le CL
you're enjoying yourself oh good looks
like Nikita's
on oh we on again oh go go go R go R go
R that's
you go
to's one here come here come here you
can
help take this go go go go go go there
you go a lot of L he's next to
you three lines on this is fun oh here
come
whose fish is he going to
eat no
one's
okay
nice you also got
one well done guys just one the hook one
left one those hook
the got it
nice all right I was
in little was off oh man nothing
happened I went about 5 minutes
nothing that oh
amazing you want to hold the fish sure
yes going to flip so just hold tight you
got it I'm going to take a photo of this
one can you hold this hold it tight
tight
TI TR again he knew I was A Yank
yeah all right one two oh that's a nice
one dad Ross all right you guys ready
one two three Nikita yours looks like
the biggest one I do have the biggest
one that was mine that is mine she just
P she just picked up the Bigg one you
just picked up the mine was on the r and
silver
one I I watched I watched yeah I did
here we go thank you 1 2 three happy
Hallelujah long lost thank you
awesome I'll go quick before they come
thank you so much all right awesome
it mine well
[Music]
done there we
go so
light line come this come this one come
this way away from that line woo yeah
it's a lot of lot of fun come this
way come this
way yes sir well done jar this
way move a little bit that way give here
com to steal here comes to steal uh W
who said
[Laughter]
that so
fun oh we cut the loop as well hey got
the
hook did you get the the hook out yeah
nice and in it
goes cting his
on oh the line is under the boat
ooh we've got a
runner bring it in
lifon how's it
[Laughter]
huh oh man this is so much
[Music]
fun one of called one of these lines
he's going to sort it out I'm going to
LIF what do you think you have
fish
check all the fish fish the fish the
fish yo water I'm not sure if you guys
can see this but there's a lot of fish
loading here in the
water is it getting closer slowly slowly
but
surely I see it yeah we have some
color yeah that's why it's so heavy
yep oh it's a
Bonito there we
go I've done
it light the line
oo well
done that's why soy
[Music]
than all right guys that's the last one
we're going to go back home we're going
to go to a restaurant close by and then
we're going to have some awesome
fish
w wow this is so much
fun nice
nikit
yeah
yeah they right here so
awesome how cool is that
and look over
here how's that
so that's so much fun they
playing wo oh
he you want to come
here
wow
woo how's that Ross super cool so
cool you want to come fishing just come
to South Africa go with hu on
Africa
this is beautiful take it in it is more
and there's many are you enjoying it
Nikita it's
amazing I have never seen anything like
that this is awesome is awesome
yeah and there you can see C on in the
back oh
man so beautiful yeah you can see them
underwater as well there's a lot of
dolphins here all around us just
escorting us back to the harbor I mean
what more can you ask
for
[Music]
look at these
playing so
awesome
are you enjoying yourself nit amazing
amazing man so this has been here for
almost 25 30 years uh it was a floating
crane that been to past C of storms in
the storm cable snapped and it's final
resting price sure uh every every time
there's a storm we think it's going to
fall over uh she doesn't want to go
sure as we come around the front there
we can see the on the back something
about
Mary
Amer you guys are
everywhere the See's written right there
American there's a lot of seals here now
you guys will understand why we had to
buy battle some of them because there's
many this Island's actually not full of
the moment during breeding season it
just be full of seals completely full of
seals oh
okay so there's a lot all eating our
fish yeah
yeah look at that huge one aast like a
w
smell you guys can't smell this but it
smells like a farm
here don't smell too pretty oh lovely
perfume
[Music]
nice
all right guys we are back here at the
hubor and so what we're going to do is
we're going to eat right here and ask
them to prepare the fish for us they
have a nice Lookout restaurant right
here right over there we wanted to do a
barbecue but I don't feel too good still
my stomach and so we're just going to
eat it here and show you what the meat
looks like guys thank you so much that
was awesome thank you yes gr cry tonight
no no no no for
[Music]
sure this the restaurant right yeah you
can find it on
YouTube I Believe Sean's going to bring
in your fish we going to cook it for you
yes awesome thank you thank you so much
all right here we
go all right guys here we are we have
the Bonito and uh let's taste
it that was fast repare it very fast HH
it's good and Ros you have not tried
this before I never tried it before
but I'm looking forward to all
right
um is it good it's so
good fresh C fresh C here we go is the
moment
um I must have the biggest one eh
[Music]
sure that's all M looks good Daniel yeah
prepar
M and there we
go how is it awesome awesome you guys
right thank you liking anything else no
it's so good yeah thank you that's it
guys thank you for watching subscribe if
you haven't done so already we bring out
weekly videos and then you will see
content like this see you next video
cheers